you guys do have a game in philly in a  couple of weeks do you think you can be  ready for that you know physically  mentally you know i imagine that's a  pretty i hope so  you guys do have a game in philly in a  couple of weeks do you think you can be  ready for that you know physically  mentally you know i imagine that's a  pretty i hope so  you guys do have a game in philly in a  couple of weeks do you think you can be  ready for that you know physically  mentally you know i imagine that's a  pretty i hope so  you guys do have a game in philly in a  couple of weeks do you think you can be  ready for that you know physically  mentally you know i imagine that's a  pretty i hope so